- Welcome, everyone.
I am really excited to welcome
Dr. Andrew Harris here today,
not least because his work
on Angkorian archeology
resonates with the important
work of our recently
departed dear colleague,
the archeologists Michael Cole,
who as many of you know,
has had a long history of important work
into Angkorian archeology.
And also as many of you know,
here at Yale we have a long-standing
scholarly engagement with Cambodia
under the stewardship of
my wonderful colleague,
Ben Kiernan in the history department.
I'm also excited for the
ways that Andrew's work
might intersect with a burgeoning
interest in Buddhist studies here at Yale,
which is guided by another
of my wonderful colleagues,
one, Tsu Kim,
who is also the chair of the
Council of East Asian Studies.
Dr. Harris recently
completed his PhD in archeology
at the University of Toronto,
where he is currently still based
while directing the Angkor Vihara Project,
which is a collaboration
between Cambodia's ops
around national authority
and the Archeology Center of
the University of Toronto,
which is dedicated to
the research excavation
and publication of early
Theravada Buddhist archeology at Angkor.
Dr. Harris is a previous
recipient of the The Robert
HN Ho Dissertation Fellowship
in Buddhist Studies
and has published his work
in World Archeology in Medieval Worlds,
with upcoming publications
and (indistinct)
ACA, Asian archeology,
and the Brill handbook in memory studies,
which we just heard about briefly
from my colleague Wang Chung.
I have much more to
say about Andrew's work
and how excited I am to have him here,
but nobody came here to listen to me.
So I'm gonna pause here
and just ask you all to join me
as we welcome Dr. Andrew
Harris to our virtual series.
His talk is entitled,
"The Introduction of Theravada
Buddhism to Angkor, Cambodia,
circa 13th through 16th centuries,
mapping and interpreting religious change
through the archeological record."
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Harris.
(Erik clapping)
- So I wanna thank, of course,
the Center for Southeast Asian Studies
for inviting me to their
Brownbag Seminar Series.
It is a great honor
to be able to present all in front of you.
As Erik mentioned, my
name is Andrew Harris.
I've never been called doctor
so many times in a row at this point.
So I'm very happy about that.
I'm a Research Associate
at the Archeology Center of
the University of Toronto,
and I'm also a sessional lecturer
at Trent University, Durham.
So before I get started,
I want to acknowledge several people,
organizations and funding bodies
who have been integral to
getting my research completed
and completing my dissertation.
Especially those members of
APSARA National Authority
who have been generous
with granting us permits
and rights to excavate the incredible
archeological record
of Cambodia and Angkor.
So today's talk is
primarily going to cover,
as the title suggests,
the religious transition and
transformation of Angkor,
and notably, Angkor Thom in Cambodia.
And we're gonna cover
a few distinct topics.
First, starting with religion, statecraft,
and temple cosmology,
and what is often an acronymstickly
known as "Indianized"
Cambodia and Southeast Asia.
I'm gonna cover a little
bit about Angkor Thom,
the theater of early Theravada Buddhist
place-making at Angkor,
what entails Buddhist terrace archeology
and Theravada monastic
construction at Angkor.
Then we'll talk about converted temples,
which are the major evidence
for evolving perceptions
of past religious spaces.
Then I will talk about social memory,
a heuristic known as foci of memory,
which I'll discuss what that is later,
and how that affected
Buddhist terrace construction
as well as the 16th century
restoration of Angkor Wat,
which is probably the best known event
within Angkor's Theravada
Buddhist archeological record.
And then finally,
I'll discuss briefly how
mapping religious transition
in the archeological record
might take place.
But the major thesis woven
to this presentation is that,
Theravada Buddhism could
not have been successful
in its spread at Angkor without
a standardized reckoning
with Angkor's temple spaces.
As a case study almost similar
to the adoption of Christianity in Rome,
with admittedly a less
pilfered archeological record.
We asked the question of how
religious transition occurs
within established religious societies,
and how can we map this through
the archeological record.
The Angkorian or Khmer Empire
was a geopolitical entity,
which at its peak,
encompass much of Thailand,
Laos, and Southern Vietnam
from the 9th century
to the 15th century CE,
although forms a single
episode within a continuous
uninterrupted Cambodian
culture and civilization,
which have existed since at
least the second millennium BC.
The region of Angkor which
is shown on the right,
was the beating heart and is
founded within a 1000 square
kilometer area of urban
and religious development,
including temples, monasteries,
walls, embankments,
canals, road, and a massive
infrastructure of
undocumented wooden buildings.
This area which is often seen
as a single urban entity
is purported to have been
the world's largest
pre-industrial settlement
with population estimates
ranging between 750,000 to a million.
And essential to understanding
Angkor's development is the
establishment of Indic religion,
both Hinduism and Buddhism in Cambodia.
These traditions arrived
in Southeast Asia initially
via maritime trade or over land between
the 2nd century BCE and 5th century CE,
and were first recorded by Chinese traders
who noted that Cambodian policies
practiced both traditions
during, at least 5th to 7th century CE.
Just to back up a moment,
there are two schools of Buddhism practice
that were practiced
within Cambodian history.
We're going to the Vajrayana Buddhism
on the table for a minute,
but these are Theravada
Buddhism and Mahayana Buddhism.
In the simplest terms,
the major difference is the
latter's focus on collective
enlightenment to the
worship of bodhisattvas
or Buddhist saints,
and the construction of great works.
Theravada Buddhism,
which is also known as
Sinhalese Buddhism is derived
from the teachings of the Pali Canon
from the Mahavihara
Monastery in Sri Lanka,
practiced there since the 2nd century BCE,
which were in turn,
reinterpreted by populations
in Burma and Thailand
in the following millennia.
This important point emphasizes
that only in scripture
are these traditions similar
to what is found in South Asian material.
Southeast Asia created traditions
that were tied into
indigenous forms of rulership
and religious practices
surrounding the elements;
water, which often became
associated with the much
later idea of oriented despotism
and ancestral veneration.
Therefore, this process of
hybridization of Indic culture
and indigenous rulerships
often known as the
Indianization of Southeast Asia
based off the work of the
prominent 20th century,
epigrapher George Coedes and others.
Important too is that this
occurred in (murmurs).
It was not a specific event adopting
Indic religion and culture,
and more often occured between
polities in Southeast Asia,
rather than between
South and Southeast Asia.
For example, between
Thailand and Cambodia,
which was the spread
of Theravada Buddhism.
Hindu and Buddhist worship,
which is known collectively
as Brahman or Buddhism
due to their shared power
structures within Cambodia
and other Southeast Asian polities,
became a way to validate
and consolidate rule
over divided city states and princes.
Southeast Asian polities
typically function
as centralized theocratic monarchies
ruled by a Chakravartin
or a universal ruler.
The king was the wielder
of dhamma or moral law,
and is often also incarnated
as either Hindu deity,
Shiva or Vishnu, or bodhisattva.
Typically, Angkor Shiva was
the most commonly venerated deity,
and the king's rule was manifested
through the worship of the Shiva Lingam,
a stone phallus which
combined with the Yoni,
a symbol of female fertility would bless
the farm lands and provide
a bountiful harvest.
This king provided,
or presided over a stratified
society of princes,
the Brahmanic elites,
caste artisans, merchants,
soldiers, and other skilled laborers
and non-caste agrarian peasants.
And it's often touted that only
the elites of any Southeast
Asian polity practice Hinduism.
Although this is unclear as
only a small segment of society
was in fact incorporated within
the Varna or caste system.
The majority of society was agrarian
and historian David Chandler
notes that this caste system
divided society between
those who grew rice,
and those who did not.
Within this model,
scholars have long read Southeast
Asian religious landscapes
as a direct reflection of statehood.
Archeological analysis of
Southeast Asian statehood
have with us mainly focused
on the manufacturing
environments constructed
by religious power,
namely the numerous Hindu
and Mahayana Buddhist
state temple complexes,
as well as later Theravada
Buddhist monasteries,
as our researches illuminated.
As well as their dedicatory
foundation inscriptions,
which were usually written in Sanskrit.
And temples across of
any size or importance
across the Angkorian Empire
were commonly established
as cosmograms representing Mount Meru,
the home of the 33 gods of
Hinduism ruled by Lord Indra
and a sacred access Mundee
that represented one of
the 31 planes of existence.
The central shrine
surrounded by four towers
or peaks of the mountain
as you can see here with Phnom Bakheng.
How's the primary deity?
Either a Shiva Lingam
or a statue of either
the Vishu or a Buddha.
Temples would also feature a (murmurs)
or were fronted by a (murmurs)
known as a reservoir,
representing the cosmic ocean,
and we're surrounded
by urban developments including hydrology
and perishable wooden buildings,
as also walls.
Thus, these complexes are referred
to as civic ceremonial centers.
The temple here, Phnom Bakheng,
was dedicated in 907 CE
by Angkor's first regional
king, Jayavarman the first.
And the area of Angkor is
often known as Yashodharapura.
Temples also formed at the
center of their own economies.
Damien Evans notes that as
microcosms of the King's capital,
village shrines and regional
temples across the empire
embodied the same political
and economic symbolism
as state temples on a smaller scale,
and essentially reinforced
the political and social
linkages within the network.
And through his analysis of economic
transactions found within epigraphy,
most notably the inscription at Ta Prohm,
which is the temple illustrated
here from the 11th century.
Kenneth R Hall surmise that
temples controlled land,
the labor on the land and
the lands productive output,
and thus formed foci of economic
systems and political mechanisms.
Temples administered the
distribution of resources,
upheld social structures
through ritual and settlement,
featured indentured laborers
tied to the temple known as Khon,
and villages were in fact tied
to temples administration.
These were recorded in many inscriptions,
for example, at the temple of Preah Khan,
which was constructed
in the late 12th century
under the great King
Jayavarman the seventh,
which administered 5,324
villages, totalling 97,840 people,
and had an attached retinue of dancers,
priests, and temple staff.
The civic ceremonial center,
which will be the focus of
today's talk is Angkor Thom,
a three by three kilometer
walled in moated citadel
constructed in the late 12th century
during the rule of the great
Mahayana Buddhist King
Jahavarman the seventh,
as the centerpiece of this
complete reenvisioning
and transformation of
the Angkorian heartland.
Angkor Thom was constructed
as a manifestation
of the churning of the ocean of milkiness.
And in this tale of Vedic mythology,
the asuras or demons
gained control of heaven,
forcing King Indra of
Mount Meru into exile.
And these demons sought
the elixir of mortality
from the cosmic ocean for themselves.
Vishnu who himself sought to
return Indra to his throne,
employed the devas, or
collectively the gods,
to help the asuras for a time,
with promise to keep the elixir inhabit.
In his act scene to balance
the universal forces of good and evil,
the devas and the asuras began
to churn the cosmic ocean
using the Naga Vasaki
as a churning mechanism.
The asuras chose the
Mountain Mandara (murmurs)
as their churning post,
which would create the elixir,
but the mountain began
to sink into the water,
and Vishnu then transformed the...
Or it transformed into a turtle,
one of it's many avatars known as Kurma,
and stabilized the mountain.
And one, in fact,
one of the many Abhiseka
or coronation rites
to describe Angkorian Kings
was their drinking of
the elixir of immortality
as a validation to kingship.
In reference to Angkor Thom's layout,
the devas and asuras still
align the city's five gateways
holding enormous Naga serpents,
and the animatic Bayon Temple,
which we'll get to shortly,
formed Mount Mandara (murmurs),
although excavations have not indicated
whether there is in fact a
giant turtle under the temple.
As a walled urban area,
Angkor Thom is also referred to as a city,
and is crisscrossed by an
orthogonal road grid alongside
a sophisticated hydraulic
system of canals and moats,
which dictated the construction
of new settlements.
The construction of the
citadel also swallowed up
Angkor's earlier political hub,
which was centered on the late 9th century
wild-walled palace complex,
which is noted as a central zone
in the diagram to the bottom right,
from which successive
Kings continued to rule.
The fifth of five arterial roads,
known as the Victory Gate road,
originally ran eastward
from the royal palace
and linked the complex
to the great east borough
constructed by Angkor's first
king, Jayavarman the first.
To get an extent of the
size of this borough,
it's 7.8 by 2.1 kilometers, large.
Angkor Thom is also home, finally,
to the overwhelming majority
of archeological evidence
for the initial adoption
and dissemination of Theravada Buddhism.
Jayavarman the seventh
deserves a bit of background
as his brief subordination of Hinduism
from Mahayana Buddhism is
relevant to our conversation
on the religious transition
in the archeological record.
Jayavarman was reportedly
converted to this religion
by his first wife prior to
the beginning of his rule
and an enormous collection of
inscriptions from his reign
emphasize the bodily ills of the subjects
became the spiritual sufferings.
The king therefore had
envisioned themselves
an incarnation of either the
bodhisattva Avalokitesvara,
who represented compassion
or the Supreme Buddha,
who sat at the nexus of compassion wisdom.
The face towers on many structures
constructed during his reign.
As you can see in the bottom right here
are thought to represent
this overwhelming cult of personality.
And in any case,
Jayavarman sought to ease
the suffering of the subjects
through the construction of brick works
and territorial consolidation.
And in commencing the program,
both the specific projects
and the order in which
they were completed indeed correlate
with architectural styles and
building schemes undertaken
during the reign of
earlier Hindu monarchs.
Using the substantial
translations and inscription
by George Coedes and others,
epigrapher Felix Stansley
was able to map out
a rhythm of three moments
royal construction across
multiple reign periods.
And these would comprise, first,
the foundations of public interest
and the renewal of state authority.
The second,
the completion of an
ancestral temple or temples.
And third, the establishment
of the temple mountain
celebrating the lingam or royal cult.
For Jayavarman's rule,
the first rhythm included a
vast infrastructural program,
including the repaving
of the empire's highways
alongside the construction of rest houses
and a whole infrastructure of hospitals
and fire shrines associated with him.
The second was the
construction of two satellite
civic ceremonial centers,
Ta Prohm and Preah Khan,
dedicated to his mother and
father in central Angkor.
And the third was a temple
was a mountain of his own,
the Bayon Temple at the
center of Angkor Thom.
This enigmatic temple,
which is defined by 54 face towers
sits at the convergence
of four of the five
citadels architectural roads.
And the temple again is both
an extension of the churning
of the ocean of milk myth,
as well as a more traditional
incarnation of Mount Meru.
Additionally, the Bayon was
constructed as a complex
architectural pantheon club
for (murmurs) Buddhist deities
featuring shrines to Buddhas
and bodhisattvas alongside Shiva, Vishnu,
Rishi, Ganesh, and others.
And it was no doubt,
the spiritual heart of
Jayavarman's vision of empire,
creating an umbrella of deities
and thus the Hindu
elites who worship them,
which he ruled over.
The Bayon would indeed
maintain this position of power
at the center of Angkor
until the abandonment of the citadel in
the 15th century or believed abandonment.
And as I'll discuss in a few slides,
the Bayon also formed an important focus
for Theravada Buddhist
construction within Angkor Thom.
And as a result of the
enormous building campaign,
which defined his rule,
Jayavarman's architectural
footprint is arguably
the largest of any Angkorian king,
but no distinct Angkorian
civic ceremonial centers
followed the foundation of Angkor Thom,
although the reason for this is disputed.
One suggestion by Damian
Evans is that Jayavarman
citadel and infrastructure already
encompassed so much of
Angkor's urban heartland,
that it no longer made sense to construct
an entirely new capital from scratch.
For instance, the creation
of a new urban center
would likely require the
retooling of any number of canals
within Angkor's hydraulic system,
a move that was likely unfeasible
due to a gradual population decline
and damage to Angkor's hydrology forecast
will begun during the 13th century,
which was primarily due
to climatic fluctuations
and over-exploitation,
although these are all
topics for another day
and a scholar far more
versed in this (indistinct).
The 13th century is also uniquely marked
with the return of the
royal call to Hinduism,
thought to have been
spearheaded by an intensive
campaign of iconoclasm under
the reign of Jayavarman the eightth,
as you can see here on the right,
by this hacked out Buddha
image at Preah Khan.
And Jayavarman the eighth
patronage of Hinduism
also came with some original
religious construction,
although not in the same
capacity as the earlier monarchs.
And the last ancient within Angkor,
the Mangalartha dedicated to Vishnu,
was constructed in 1295 CE.
Although it's unclear whether
Mahinda Buddhism is continuously
practiced after this period
or whether it was simply an episode
within Angkor's history of corresponding
with the Jayavarman the seventh.
During the 13th century, if
not even during the late 12th,
a third religion began to
gain a foothold in Cambodia,
in part due to Jayavarman's
consolidation of the Western
border of his empire.
This was Theravada Buddhism,
which as I previously noted,
is derived from Southeast Asia
interpretations of Sinhalese Buddhism.
Oregionally analysis of the Dvaravati
material culture of Thailand by scholars,
such as Stephen Murphy
suggests that Buddhism
was practiced in the region
directly proximate to Cambodia,
at least by the 6th
century CE if not earlier.
These Dvaravati polities notably those
on the Khorat plateau of
central eastern Thailand
were almost always situated
on the frontiers of several
larger imperial geo bodies,
for example, the Burmese of Pogon
and the Khmer of Angkor.
The nature of the medieval
Southeast Asian state is often
characterized as a
modular or cosmic circle.
And this is so hyper and
hypothesized by scholars
such as Stanley Tebana and O.W Walters
to emplace the relationship of kings
in a state of balanced
divine power radiating
from a concentric point
across a highly spiritualized territory,
which we might call an empire.
In this model,
the borders of Southeast Asian empires,
I guess we could call them that,
continuously waxed and waned
constantly emphasizing the center.
But very little focus has been given
to the cultural transmission,
which occurred in this
often ignored frontier
due to archeological and
religious nationalism,
cementing history within modern borders.
Although Burmese sources indicate
that Jayavarman the seventh's
son, Tom Melinda, in fact,
reportedly visited the Mahavihara
with Burmese monks in 1180 CE.
The first account of
Theravada Buddhist practice
in material cultured Angkor
comes from the 1296 CE
writings of Zhou Daguan
entitled, "The Customs of Cambodia".
Zhou was an envoy sent
from China by (murmurs)
to survey and document the regions
that China saw to be under the dominion,
and also possibly because a new
king, Indravarman the third,
had been crowned a year earlier.
Zhou arrived at Angkor Thom
and through a somewhat fragmented
perception of foreign customs and culture,
observed as many as three
practicing religions.
Brahmans, which he named specifically,
worshipers venerating a block of stone
would possibly be Shiva worshipers
and Buddhists whose
monks wore saffron robes
and worship large images of
the Buddha in grooved halls,
the first mention of
any structure resembling
what we found in the archeological record.
Zhou also importantly notes
that every family practiced Buddhism,
which suggests that the
construction of the Mangalartha,
a year earlier, was a product of just
one of the traditions of practice being,
or being practiced at Angkor
rather than some
overnight flip the switch,
as it somewhat suggested
earlier scholarship.
It's likely that Theravaaa
had been there for a time.
The King Indravarman the third
was also a practicing Buddhist,
and Zhou notes,
generally when leading a
return into the palace,
he had to visit a small gold pagoda
with a Buddha in front of it.
Onlookers all had to kneel down
and touch their head on the ground.
Theravada Buddhist practice
after this point
is thought to gradually gain ground
on the remaining Hindu
traditions as a religion
widely practiced across
all social classes.
And while hierarchy indeed
continued to exist within the ritual
performed and practiced in monasteries,
rulership appears to be less tied
to connection with Hindu dates.
The epigraphic language in fact
shifted from Sanskrit to Pali.
The canon language assemblies
Buddhism in the 14th century,
and an inscription exists from 1309 CE,
at Svay Kok Chek Temple
in Northwestern, Cambodia,
which describes the King's application
for the life of a bhikkhu or a monk,
which seems unprecedented.
The king would typically
have died in his position
if he wasn't overthrown or killed.
The last inscription dedicated to Shiva
appears on the Bayon from 1327 CE,
which is no worthy as
much for its dedication
to a Hindu king as its
inscription on a monument,
which may have kept its
significance as a pantheon,
but certainly remained
emblematic of royal authority.
Theravada Buddhism also
introduced a new material culture
comprising of new religious
and monastic spaces
called Vihara or prayer halls,
which are derived,
likely derive from those founded
within Buddhist polities
in Northern Thailand,
such as Sukhothai,
which was established in 13th century
or the Dvaravati polities,
which had in mind,
which by the excavation of
several boundary stones in Kulen
may have had a minor presence in Cambodia.
Archeologists refer to these
distinct edifices at Angkor
as either Buddhist terraces,
a translation of the French classifier
Terrasse Bouddhique or Preah Vihear,
Khmer translation of Vihara.
The distinction though
is that Buddhist terraces
comprise the archeological
substructure remains
and Preah Vihear represent
the edifice in which Buddhist
rites were performed.
Like temples the floor
plan of a Buddhist terrace.
Oh, that went by.
Buddhist terrace shown here
with the example of Angkor
Thom Vihear or HTP seven
was to a degree standardized.
That said, it's currently
impossible to determine
the entire structure because
the wooden superstructure,
which could have made up
up to 90% of the building
has in all cases disintegrated
due to Cambodia's general climate.
Although from comparisons
with roof structures
depicted in release on temples,
they were likely a little different
than monastic structures
found in Cambodia today.
In any case, almost all of
these structures face east
derived from the positioning of temples
in reference to Shiva,
and focalized the single colossal Buddha
on a statute by statute
on a raised stone placed
at the western extremity.
Above the wooden superstructure,
the edifice would have been typically
topped with a tiled roof.
The use of roof tiles is significant
because Zhou Daguan explicitly
described sanctuary laws
associated with using tile only
in elite or royal buildings,
which puts these buildings
potentially under royal patronage.
Indravarman the third, for example,
is known to have dedicated
land for Preah Vihear construction,
and from the 1309
inscription previously noted.
So this indicates that the
king's land i.e all land,
was by the court to the Tsonga
or monastic order to
build a local monastery.
The most significant racial
delineator Preah Vihear space,
a sima, a series of blessed stone orbs
or other stone deposits used to demarcate
ordination spaces with
not Theravada monastery.
Angkorian monastic communities adopted
the early Djavarati tradition of erecting
prominent stone markers or sima stones
over these deposits in an eight by one
or eight by two formation of the cardinal
and sub cardinal boundaries
of each Preah Vihear.
Sima in fact had been the
single most consistent variable
and classifier of these former
Preah Vihear sites during surveys,
and shows significant variation
in both style and craftsmanship.
In turn, the placement of sima
surrounding of a Vihara is unique
within Theravada practice
in Southeast Asia,
as these buildings would
typically be separated
into a Vihara and an Ubosot
Vihara or ordination hall,
and may represent a uniquely
Angkorian vocalization of
Theravada ritual space,
which might be argued to descend
from the centralization
of a community in ritual
on a single structure
existent in Hindu practice.
Highlighted amongst the supporting
infrastructure of walls,
causeways and minor image
houses known as cellar,
a select number of
Buddhist terrace complexes
feature reliquary
monuments of varying sizes
for more familiar,
familiarly known stupas.
Which either stand as a separate structure
or are directly attached
to the main complex.
Reliquaries served as
repositories of statuary,
treasure, and funerary remains.
And at present were directly
west of the Preah Vihear
on an elixir trajectory
with both the central sanctuary
in Eastern (indistinct).
Based on the self structural remains
two main relequary
forms existed at Angkor.
The first is known as a Prah That.
It resembles a small temple tower with,
this's almost entirely unique to Angkor,
while more traditional
bell-shaped reliquaries,
locally known as Chedi were introduced
later in the 14th or 15th century.
(murmurs) as a product
have growing Thai influence
on Angkorian architecture.
In the lower right corner
or lower left corner,
you can actually see a possible
indication of the superposition
between these two types of structures,
which is important to remember
when we discussed temporal
conversions corresponding
with Theravada Buddhists
perceptions of temple space,
as well as how it evolved.
And on the right there are as evidence,
there are smaller funerary stupas
that surround more prominent
Buddhist terrace structures.
This one surrounds a Buddhist
terrace by the Bayon Temple.
The liDAR map illustrates the
current known extent of Angkor
Thom's mass development and comprises
Buddhist terraces with
and without sima stones,
all that we found so
many as votive deposits
at the foot of the central
sanctuary pedestals,
that's very likely many were excavated
from the original positions
during later periods.
This amounts to 72 Preah Vihear
within a nine square kilometer area.
And while I think this
number might be slightly low,
the 13 identified with
temples and infrastructure
in central Angkor is
definitely understated
and requires further investigation.
Still, this number represents
a massive building campaign
centered on Angkor Thom,
which is through radiometric
dating we've determined,
likely primarily occurred
during the 14th century,
if not slightly earlier.
We're currently exploring the
possibility of a purposeful
monastic construction
boom during this period,
but this theory requires
far more expedition.
My methodology in mapping these structures
require the use of colonial
French hand drawn maps
from the early 20th century
overlaid with modern LiDAR
collected by the greater Angkor project
and APSARA authority.
And then two years of
ground survey and catalog.
Thanks to this effort,
APSARA granted us permission
to excavate test fits
across several sites at Angkor Thom,
which became the basis of our
collaborative Angkor Vihara Project.
The results and observations
that I've presented thus far,
and will present,
are based on four seasons of
field work within this region,
but at least two more are still come.
And just to give you a
sense of the range of dates
associated with Buddhist
terraces habitation,
which come from three of
our four excavation sites,
but across Angkor Thom,
as well as the context in
which some of these charcoal
samples we dated come from.
For example, on the bottom left,
this one charcoal sample came between two,
from between two (murmurs) bones
underneath the hand of a
foot-long earth touching Buddha
at the site Preah Vihear's
dismantled central sanctuary
or another came from the
base of a Buddhist staircase
that we had excavated into.
These of course are not
the only dates we gathered,
which included several
stratigraphic samples
dating from the 11th to 12th centuries.
This suggests that many
Buddhists terrace sites
were in fact constructed in
areas of previous occupation,
either residential or even religious,
based on the excavation
on the upper right,
a vote of deposit of a
single rounded gypsum stone
dated from this earlier period.
This was a date associated.
Although Preah Vihear collectively
formed the most common
Theravada Buddhist place of
worship town within Angkor,
and clearly formed the
anchors of religious
transitioning in community,
rarely these edifices has
given the same religious,
social or political agencies,
the temples which proceeded them.
This is odd considering the
focality of the modern Wat
in Cambodia and Cambodian daily life.
Olivia De Bernon was one of the first few,
one of the first scholars
who asserted this agency
likely through his comparison
with both contemporary trans-regional
and modern Cambodian examples.
While buying his view
monasteries served as a
grounds for (indistinct)
for the construction of
stupas and reliquaries,
for resource distribution,
many future treasuries,
and also served as
repositories for donations
or offerings which were typically
given in the form of statues, gold
or arms of food and insets.
Preah Vihear are also believed to have had
a population of indentured
laborers tied to the monastery,
Quaspy villages and likely
functioned as anchors of local
or regional economies in a
similar manner to Hall's model.
Although, of course, this is
thus far entirely undocumented.
My own research which through
archeological analysis
has indeed verified many of
De Bernon's observations,
has sought to explore and explain
the diversity of architecture
within the uniform floor plan.
With this thus acknowledge the possibility
that the dissemination of Buddhism
was local rather than centralized,
despite land being donated by the king.
This might help explain
the size of Preah Vihear,
the types and qualities
of materials were used.
Our main diacritic is quarried sandstone,
which would become from a
quarry in the Koh Han Hills
to the north Northeast,
versus recycled sandstone,
which likely came from a dismantle temple.
As well as the
craftsmanship of associates
statuary and sima.
The number of extant statue pedestals,
the number of luxury goods,
most notably Chinese export
wares, gold leaf ornaments,
and green glazed Khmer celadon boxes,
and the number of funerary
and reliquary monuments
associated with each complex.
Varying access to resources and artistry
by monastic populations indeed
may have been a product
of local social status.
The wealthier your patrons
in most families were
the more extravagant
your prayer hall maybe.
These ideas run in sharp contrast
to the ways Angkorian scholars previously
interpreted the original material output
in development of Theravada in Cambodia.
In fact, prayer halls and
other monastic structures
are often omitted from
discussions of Theravada Buddhist
development and Angkor entirely.
Often relegated as secondary
and thus unimportant monuments
prior to radiometric
analysis Buddhist monuments
such as these were thought to generally
date from the 15th and 19th century,
prior to the superficial (indistinct)
known as the post
Angkorian or middle period,
which was framed as a Cambodian dark age,
following the disputed
followed Angkor in 1431
and proceeding the
establishment of the colonial
French protectorate in 1963,
a very romanticized narrative.
Angkorian scholars focused
on temples and inscription
saw an absence of these
two major cultural staples,
temples and inscriptions
as a reflection of Angkor's
decline and a breakdown
of its political order,
and most notably important
for the early colonial French grand jury.
Conversely, a select
number of Buddhist scholars
influenced by the late
19th and 20th century
Buddhist nationalist movements
across Southeast Asia
corresponding with independence,
interpreted Angkorian Theravada
as almost a revolution
against the multi radical
Hindu Mahayana of
Buddhist state structures.
And painted Theravada as
a sort of Buddhist utopia,
especially in reference
to the contemporary
Thai Buddhist kingdom Sukhothai.
And while there's certainly
some validity to the idea
that Theravada warship
transcended social classes
in a way Hindu caste maybe not,
as well as the ease at which,
of which members of lay classes
could be indoctrinated as monks
thus dividing or thus bringing together
those who grew rice and those who did not.
It's very unlikely any sort
of social revolution occurred
as society remained
stringently hierarchical,
and most importantly stable.
But if materiality and
landscape analysis remain
the focus of investigations to answer
these questions of Angkorian religion.
The study of architecture
in the surrounding
urban settlement of monasteries
are especially important
to understanding the dynamics of a period,
from which inscriptions
are no longer extant yet
construction is continuing.
For example, in reference
to the notion of Mundell
I discussed earlier,
the correlation of size shown
here indirectly replicates the
focality of the cosmic
center of Angkor Thom,
including its arterial roads,
with a peripheral boundary
as smaller structures.
Each structure and complex likely
fulfill the same virtual functions,
but evidently those
structures near the center
had the capacity to host
larger congregations
and feature elegantly carved,
likely quarried sandstone substructures.
Epigrapher (indistinct) for example,
suggested that monks
may have been ordained
at more prominent Preah Vihear complexes
and built their own prayer halls,
where they lived with the
resources at their disposal.
And their Preah Vihear's
similar to temple's
served as satellites of
political religious authority
for the regions in which
they were constructed.
The use of recycled stone to build these
smaller structures on the
periphery is notably abundant,
as well stressing the inequality
between monastic populations.
Also key to upholding political
and religious authority
across the Angkorian
Empire was the standardized
replication of a central
religious sanctuary.
One wish in our understanding in Mandala
unified the elites of the
state under a common worldview
and thus an imperial rule,
which strengthened the
periphery of the state
in relation to the center.
Although no evidence has
thus far been identified
to suggest a central
monastic help within Angkor.
The great monastery of Tep Pranam,
Angkor's largest Buddhist
terrace complex is the most
probable candidate to fulfill this role
based on existing archeological evidence.
Tep pranam which is found
directly north of the royal palace
was continuously expanded
by unknown factions
under unknown monarchs
and no inscription exists
to dedicate to it's initial foundation.
However, an inscription
was found there in 1908,
that had been moved from a Buddhist ashram
dedicated by the 9th century
king Jayavarman the first at
least five centuries earlier,
and Tep Pranam was actually thought
to be the site of an early Hindu building.
The same inscription and
its accompanying ashram
was also rededicated by the 11th century
king Jayavarman the first,
who despite constructing a
temple mountain was a Buddhist.
The steelie clearly
was moved with purpose,
as other foundation steelies
unrelated to Buddhist
entirely have been found at other
Buddhist terrace complexes as deposits,
and potentially signify Tep Pranam
as an established royal sanctuary.
The actual ashram, which
was identified fully
in the early 2000s is found
more than four miles
away and does not appear
to have been used since it's
11th century rededication.
Visually, if correct,
and of course we need to excavate more
to establish the specifics.
There appears to be a clear aim
by Angkor's Buddhist
populations and rulers
to ensure a smooth transition between
past and present principles
of religious space.
But how did Angkorian populations deal
with the overwhelming number of Hindu
and Mahayana Buddhist
temples in their midst.
Close to five centuries
of temple mountains
are found within the capital central zone.
Still, and it's not yet clear
whether any temples were
demolished to build buildings
or build monastic buildings despite
the abundant use of recycled sand stone.
But the original temple space
is a cellar holding a lingam,
no longer exists at any of these tables.
So how were these places reconciled
with a new built environment,
especially since a large
number of the temples
were in fact converting?
Well, first as Zhou Daguan described
a period of religious pluralism
followed both Jayavarman
eight's Hindu iconoclasm,
and the institutionalization of Theravada
in the late 13th century.
So this may have not even
been an issue until the 14th,
which marks the point
when many Preah Vihear
were inhabited if not constructed.
But as Preah Vihear space
began to become the predominant
area of worship and Hindu practice,
and, or worship and Hindu
practices were slowly phased out.
Rather than demolishing these temples,
they were transformed or negotiated.
Only Lathum's live space,
or Edward Soja's third space,
provide key theoretical frameworks
to understanding the types of processes
embedded within converted temples
and how conversions changed over time
based on the perception
of ancient monuments.
I also wanna importantly
knowledge that this research
from an anthropological perspective
was first undertaken by
Dr. Ashley Thompson from SOAS,
whose work was an important
inspiration for my own.
One major indicator that
temples are converted
was the installation of
a prescribed iconography,
likely imported from contemporary
Thai Buddhist imagery,
which is found represented in
both standing statuary and beliefs.
Each image intentionally depicts
a specific episodes in
the life of the Buddha,
the Parinirvana image on
the lower left, for example,
illustrates the Buddha
breaking the life cycle
and passing into Nirvana after his death.
Whereas the earth touching
Buddha in the both on the right
is constructed in reference
to Buddhist defeat of the demon Mara,
asking the earth to witness
it's victory through touch.
These images are almost, almost constant,
always constant across converted temples,
and are far more uniform
than Hindu in Mahayana
Buddhist iconography,
which primarily owes to
the centuries of local
artistic development within Angkor
rather than just their import.
It's also probable that
Buddhist terraces and converted
temples were initially collectively
standardized in a layout
and temple such as Preah
Palilay in Western present Thom
thus may represent the first typed
inversions found in Angkor.
The ladders conversion, or at
least its new southern tower,
based on the diagram here,
has in fact been hypothesized
to date from the late 13th century
based on a radiometric analysis by Nara,
who currently undertaking
anastylosis at the time.
This was based,
may have been based on
continued sacredness
or scribed to the inner sanctuary
in order to standardize these monuments,
which is thought to have been converted
into a reliquary in both cases.
The placement of a Preah
Vihear fronting the temple
and either the replication
or origin of this alignment
between Buddhist terraces and reliquaries.
It was just kind of a
chicken and egg situation.
Especially through the
installation of the Preah Eintep
reliquary shows that there was an attempt
to create uniform
Angkorian Theravada space,
regardless of the edifice.
Also important to note with
these initial temple conversions
were their confinement
to smaller structures,
not the enormous state temples.
These, if they were
transformed were subject
to much larger renovations
and either a blocking up
or the overall demolition
of the Mount Meru towers.
At least one of these temples,
the 11th century Baphoun on the right
was physically transformed
during the 15th century
into a 65 meter statue
of a reclining Buddha
at Theravada at the expense
of its central sanctuary,
which is known from carbon
dates taken from iron crampons
embedded within the Buddha.
In a similar manner,
Angkor's the first temple
mountain Phnom Bakheng
was physically transformed into
a statue of a seated Buddha
similarly through the
demolition of its towers.
The research on this
installation is impossible
as early French conservators
saw it as an eyesore
and demolished it to reconstruct
the original Mount Meru in the 1920s.
And this image illustrates
it's also possible
that many prah t-hat once
accessible were blocked up
or transformed into closed
reliquaries during this period.
Archival photographs show
that this was not a modern
renovation in the red box here.
The construction of reliquaries
and temple architecture,
as well as the tempo
of temple conversions,
moving from accessible to closed
are ideas I hope to investigate in future
expedition season at Angkor,
as we create a better idea of when
the central Hindu temple
space was not only abandoned,
but seen as negligible or
even negatively charged.
The placement of Buddhist terraces
has thus far been proven
to be rarely arbitrary.
As I previously indicated in
our excavations have on earth
radiometric, artifactual structural
and even votive remains associated
with earlier domestic or religious
dwellings on the same site.
However, the most unique
patterns of Preah Vihear
occur in relation to temples,
as well as arterial roads.
Based on connections to these elements,
I refer to these alignments
as foci of memories of working hypothesis.
Whereby memory refers to the continued
significance and reverence
for ancient things over time,
and the reckoning of the past
the populations undertook
when establishing their futures
across multi temporal landscapes.
Working with our data,
I've established a few important
caveats for each focus.
Each appears to honor and
re-legitimize or reify
a Romano-Buddhist sanctuary
within his place in the landscape.
which in turn reinforced and legitimated
the original layout of Angkor Thom,
it's road ways and its
individual monuments.
Renovations are also,
and conversions are also common
amongst temples that anchor foci.
The key concept as well,
number two is old infrastructure
in new Preah Vihear
found with a niche focus embody
a reciprocal relationship
were by neither is sacred within
Theravada Buddhist
landscape without the other.
Third, what is found in Angkor Thom
is the culmination of each
focus and it is unknown
whether these areas were developed
gradually or immediately.
However, none of them,
none of the foci are found
in any epigraphic records
and are inferred through
analysis of map data,
and thus the flexibility of this juristic
enables additional interpretation.
So this is just a hypothesis,
but it seems to have
some spatial relevance.
The Bayon for example,
formed the focal point of the concentric
layout of Buddhist terraces,
none of which are identical.
This suggests that focus
was created gradually
rather than as a single
act of construction.
And that monasteries in the focus
were not created by a single
faction, but several over time.
Still by coincidence or by some continuous
perception of the Bayon the
layout today resembles a mandola
surrounding the temple and
clearly cements the Bayon
as the continuous pivot of the citadel.
Another examples found in the
form of a staggered line of
Buddhist terraces spanning
the entire longitudinal
thoroughfare of Angkor Thom.
only interrupted by the central zone,
which during survey we called
the north south gate road zigzag.
Interestingly, Zhou Daguan attributes
some significance to at least
the Southern portion of
this route in his writings.
As you can see in the
quote in the bottom right
This thoroughfare ultra features
a large number of structures
with fire brick remains.
Bricks interestingly had
not been used on mass
in Angkorian architecture
since the late 10th
or early 11th centuries,
when they were replaced almost entirely
by a combination of
sandstone and litreage.
And it's therefore likely
bricks are re-introduced
to Angkorian architecture
by means of expanding Thai influence
where brick and plaster construction
during this period are abundant.
Additionally, brick renovations appear
on top of sandstone and litreage.
So it's likely that this
was a later installation.
We excavated one of the
structures along the route,
and like other Preah
Vihear across the citadel,
we did a bone deposit
near the central sanctuary
to the 14th century.
According to contemporary Thai sources,
Angkor was successfully attacked
in 1431 by armies from the
kingdom of Ayutthayan.
Ayutthayan the Buddhist embodied
the same rigid social hierarchy,
standardized replication of architecture,
divine rulership rights,
and even the idea of
constructing a temple mountain
at their island capital
north of Bangkok as within Hindu Angkor,
and the geopolitical
expansion of Ayutthaya
between the 14th and 15th centuries,
it's thought to have been
a major cause of the
decommission of Angkor
as the capital Cambodia.
While Cambodia's ruling class
left the region for a series of capitals
surrounding modern Phnom Penh
over the ensuing three centuries.
Scholars such as Michael Vickery
highlight the possibility
that Ayutthaya prince occupied Angkor Thom
at some point during the mid 15th century,
but for all intents and purposes,
the old citadel was no longer
a significant civic ceremonial center.
Angkor too was now positioned
squarely on Cambodia's frontier.
Radiometric data found,
found across Angkor Thom,
including from our own research,
indicate the possibility of a 15th century
upper limit of occupation.
Angkor was taken from the Angkor Thom mode
by Dan Penny's team from
the University of Sydney,
suggest overall hydraulic
neglect during this period,
which he describes as swamp like.
Seriations of Chinese ceramics undertaken
by Hiadara, David Brotherson and others,
show an absence of Li dynasty
that is late 14th and 15th century,
blue and white Chinese export
wares at Preah Vihear sites,
as opposed to Song dynasty
11th to 14th century,
as well as Yuan dynasty,
(indistinct) and white wares,
which indicate a relative
lack of habitational
or votive activities
beyond the 15th century.
The great temple of Angkor
Wat to the south meanwhile,
was transformed into a prominent
Buddhist pilgrimage site
during the 16th century.
This conversion may have
in fact occurred earlier
as two Buddhist terraces
had been constructed there,
which according to
Cambodian world chronicles
date from the years following
Angkor's defeat by Ayutthaya.
Angkor Wat was originally constructed
by King Suryavarman the second,
during the early to mid 12th
century as a shrine to Vishnu,
and holds the recognition
as the world's largest religious monument.
The temple is known especially
for it's 1.6 kilometers
of release including an
earlier illustration of the
churning of the ocean milk.
And activity at the
temples documented in an
expansive volume of inscriptions
in the Khmer language
dating from 1546 CE onwards.
And it was continuously
patronized by the royal family
who walled up the old central sanctuary
at the central most
tower with Buddha freezes
decommissioning the earlier vision cellar.
While a less destructive act from
the Bakong or Pnohm
Bakheng re-envisioning,
this blocking up of the
space clearly reflects
similar perceptions of
earlier temple sanctuaries,
as either defunct or dangerous.
Inscriptions too clearly
engage with memory
venerating the August ancestors
and Angkor's previous kings.
To conclude, the landscape
of Buddhist terraces
slash Preah Vihear illustrates
a unique and localized
adoption of Theravada Buddhism
in Angkor Thom and central Angkor.
One which was required to negotiate
the built environment of institutionalized
political religious authority,
but also propagate this
new religious practice
in a unique framework, which
would guarantee its success.
Theravada at Angkor I contend
was manifested nowhere else
the same in Southeast Asia.
The construction and placement
of these new structures
honored earlier material and
spatial ritual traditions
highlighting the importance
of core periphery relations
and religious place-making
while also serving
as an innovative advancement
with semantic Preah Vihear
as familiar religious architectures.
The incorporation of Hindu and Mahayana
Buddhist infrastructure
into Theravada Buddhist
understandings in place was
also indeed an evolving process,
although more research is
necessary to understand
any of these theoretical avenues.
And finally Angkor Thom serves
as a fascinating and important case study
for religious transition in
the archeological record.
One which unlike more prominent
civic ceremonial centers,
such as Rome, Athens, or even Sukhothai,
which was once itself a
town on the Khmer frontier,
contains a relatively
underserved archeological record
where the idealization of
history and search for origins
did not come at the expense of the sites
with more recent history,
which is aside from that
poor little Buddha of phnom Bakheng.
Ideas of social memory,
indigenous use of time,
continuity rather than the phasing
and the apicalization of history
and even modern perception
of these sacred sites
by local worshipers can easily
and accurately be analyzed here.
With local collaboration,
prioritization of Cambodian academic goals
and honoring of Angkor's everlastingly
spiritually charged nature,
being paramount to all
successful future research.
And these are just some of our goals
for the upcoming two
field seasons in 2022,
as well as one possibly in 2023.
And I'd love to hear your questions.
Again, it's been an honor
to present for all of you
at Center for Southeast
Asian Studies, and thank you.
- Thank you so much, Andrew.
This is a really a rich presentation.
I think we'll have a
lot of questions here.
So what I'd like to do is
open it up to the audience.
Andrew, maybe you can
stop the screen share,
but we may ask you to
pull up some images later,
but you seem to be pretty good
at going back and forth between it,
so we can see the faces of
people asking questions.
So if anyone has a question
I suggest you use the
raise hand function of Zoom
and then I'll call on
you and I'll keep a list
as they start appearing
to try to get an order to our questions.
So, I'll wait for a moment as
people collect their thoughts
and I look forward to hearing from you.
And so we'll start with Eric White,
Eric, go ahead.
- Hi, hi Andrew, thank you for the talk.
So I'm not a specialist of
Cambodia or Cambodian Buddhism.
- Okay.
- I work on
contemporary Thai, Thailand Thai Buddhism.
So my question is more comparative
sort of builds off of your,
some of your closing comments and it's...
It's said in this,
I'm often concerned that there is,
there is an overemphasis
on the similarities,
right, of Tibetan Buddhist cultures
and histories across the region.
You know, they all,
rather than thinking about multiple
Theravada Buddhisms in the region,
there's often a kind of a tendency
to sort of conflate beliefs and practices,
pantheons, literary
material culture sometimes.
So, in that light
how do you see
the character and dynamics
of the introduction
and consolidation of
Theravada Buddhism in Cambodia
differing from dynamics
of the introduction of Theravada
Buddhism in other regions,
right, or other polities in this,
in this pre-modern era.
You sort of mentioned,
you gestured towards these
unique local character,
and I'm wondering if you could actually,
if you could sort of itemize even,
just list out what you saw,
what you see as uniquely
in terms of the character and dynamics.
And especially if you see them
having enduring significance
for the character of Cambodian
Buddhism in a later period.
So thinking about essentially
past dependencies,
the way that initial differences
have had enduring consequences, thank you.
- That's a great question.
I think, I think coming
from my perspective,
which is more archeological
than anthological,
I can't necessarily talk to
the rites and rituals involved.
The inscriptions are lacking.
It's not quite clear how
Buddhism was first practiced.
And we like to talk about
Sinhalese Buddhism, but again,
you just can't say that.
With Angkor what we're finding
in the archeological record
is a discerning attempt to
create a worldview that makes
sense to the people and
the hierarchies that exist.
The idea that religious
dissemination is successful,
not based on chaos,
but based on continuity is
something that we're seeing
within the Angkorian archeological record.
The idea that sima,
and these are few of the
things that I had to take out,
otherwise the presentation
would've been hours,
but the architecture itself
in many of the late 13th,
early 14th century
structures is not recycled,
it's quarried,
and it's carved in a way
that almost is identical
to the way that one would enter a temple.
You see Buddhist terraces at Angkot Thom,
with ballast rates and (murmurs)
that are easily recognizable.
You see the idea that
the sanctuary is always
has it's face eastward,
and the only time it
hadn't in Angkorian history
was when the temple was
dedicated to Vishnu.
And so there seems to be
this idea that Buddhism
at Angkor is unique because
of not necessarily Hinduism,
not necessarily what was practiced before
in terms of religious
practice, but the space itself.
The idea that this is what we
know as a place of worship.
The Pratt is the temple,
it's not a question of,
it's not a question of how
are we going to include the temple,
it's where does the temple go?
It's not even a thought, it's
where does the temple go?
And over time, as I mentioned,
as Ayutthayan traditions become stronger
and geopolitically become
more dominant in the region,
you do see the shift towards
a more Thai,
not necessarily religious version,
but material version of Buddhism,
which is again, an incredibly
controversial point
in the 20th and 21st century.
But at the same time, there's a Cambodia,
there is, you're right,
a uniquely Cambodian tradition
and uniquely Thai tradition,
which admittedly comes
mostly from the 20th century
when the French essentially did not allow
Cambodian monks to travel to Thailand.
They said, you cannot
be indoctrinated here.
We're going to create our own school.
And this is the way to make
sure that our territory is
consolidated within
Cambodia is create that.
So there the tradition has been
much more modern than ancient.
And so, within early Theravada,
it's much easier to tell a distinct,
distinct different between
regions and what was adopted.
And I think maybe that gives us somewhat,
maybe that's a somewhat meandering
answer to your question,
but I think I would stand
by the idea that this was,
as I say, localized,
based on what people
knew of religious space.
- Thanks.
- No problem.
- All right, Andrew,
while we're waiting for other questions,
I wanna ask you a question about
spatial location versus
spatial orientation.
- Okay.
- And I just made this idea up,
so it may be totally unusual or strange,
but as I was listening to
you throughout the talk,
and then hearing your response
to Eric's question as well,
you were noting that the
importance of a kind of recognition
of a particular religious
space of worship.
So in a sense that's a
kind of location, right?
There's a spot on the map in a sense
that seems to have accrued meaning
as a place of religious practice
or worship or something.
And there's actually a kind of
historical respect for that.
And actually a reproduction of that space,
even if there's a shift in
the actual spatial practice
that happens in that space, right.
And then, but as you were
answering that, you also said,
well, you can really see
like when it faces east,
you know that never
happened before until this,
this orientation comes along.
And so I'm curious if
there's ways in the map...
So the location's the same,
but the orientation is turned.
And I'm wondering if there's
ways in your mapping practice
that you can systematically notice that,
and tied to this is just
another question that I had was,
as you were talking about
the kind of respect for a
previous religious practice
that had place,
even if there's a religious
transformation that happens,
that struck me as very interesting
in comparison to one little example,
you showed where there was
the smashed out Buddha image.
- Yeah.
- I think it was from
the 13th century, right?
- Mmh.
- Which is clearly not a respect
of the previous practice,
but it's still in the same place.
- It is.
- I'm just wondering
if you could play with
that idea of orientation versus location.
- Sure, what I actually had said,
well about the orientation
of Buddhists terraces
was they faced east,
which was not a shift.
It was actually something that made them
similar to Shiva temples.
It was something that
that they faced east,
which is a direction derived
from, in reverence to Indra.
And in terms of the
iconography, the iconoclasm,
it was actually something that,
when I was writing my
thesis I toyed around with,
as an earlier re-envisioning
of the Angkorian landscape.
Mahayana Buddhism was something
that was revolutionary
and new and tied to a king,
maybe one or two iings.
It's not quite clear whether
Jayavarman six ancenstor
in Jayavarman the second
was a Mahayana Buddhist,
but it was a sense that these
sanctuaries could be used,
could be reinterpreted.
All they needed was the
images gone, Jayavarman gone,
and they were still
perfectly good sanctuaries.
They still were recognizable.
They were still oriented in a
way that was understandable.
They still housed populations.
They still housed laborers,
and were the foci of all of
political and economic systems
that they were before.
So, it's an interesting,
it's an interesting idea to say the least.
And I think there,
there actually has been
a good amount of work
done on the architecture itself,
but not necessarily on what
types of things iconoclasm
and what types of asks,
what happens when an image
gets hacked out of a temple
or gets transformed?
There were actually several that were,
Buddhas were transformed into lingams
and into rishi or saints.
And so, what does that mean,
and how do we,
or how do we look more at that?
Because the way that Angkorian
history is often constructed
is that there's periods of
boom and bust continuously,
boom and bust, boom and bust.
And this one was a dramatic event.
And every time a king returned
to some sort of royal cult,
every single time there's always violence.
There's always thought to be violence.
Iconoclasm is a violent act in itself,
but it's not clear from the 13th century,
although Zhou Daguan mentions
a war with Sukhothai,
that the Angkorian kingdom
was in any sort of tumult
climatological issues aside.
So, I would like to,
I really would like to explore more
about the iconoclasm of Hinduism.
So it's, yeah,
it's something to investigate further.
I think I, again, again,
another meandering answers your question.
- Can I ask just a brief
technical follow-up question
that may be obvious to all
the archeologists in the room,
but how does when,
I can understand how one
might deit existing objects,
but how does when deit when
something was destroyed?
Like for example, the hacking
away of a Buddha face,
it removes the material so what kind of,
how does one actually deit that?
- They don't, and then
that's part of that's
part of sort of, it adds up.
And so deductive reasoning is used.
There's two theories on the iconoclasm ,
one, that it occurred during
the reign of Jayavarman the eighth,
and the second is in a sort
of newer reaction is that
it occurred during the
reign of Peramesvarapada,
who was the last Hindu king.
And according to the
Cambodian real chronicles,
he was in fact assassinated
by his gardener.
So there was Theravada
Buddhist kings after that.
So those are kind of the two ideas.
And through archeology unless
there's residue on an act,
you really can't do it.
It's all, it's all speculative.
You have to hope more epigraphy comes up.
- I see a hand up from Ward Keeler,
and Ben has appeared on video.
So I'll call on Ward Keeler first,
and then turned to Ben after that,
go ahead Ward.
- Thanks, I work in Burma and Indonesia.
So Cambodia is really
quite a foreign to me,
but I wonder if a pattern
that seems discernible
all over Southeast Asia
doesn't help your explanation.
That is to say that any site
can be seen to be a residue
of enormous amounts of power,
of spiritual power,
whatever you wanna call it.
It's just, there's a note of power there
that is available to be tapped.
So, of course you would
wanna keep the place because
the places are imbued
with that kind of power.
At the same time,
every religious reform movement is a way
for those in power
to divert more power to themselves,
to make a break with the past,
to show some sort of new
direction that enables them
to do things like, you know,
what happens in Burmese history is that,
all the monks have to be re-initiated,
which means a completely
new order to the hierarchy.
So, I just wonder if that
makes sense as a way of putting
together the different parts
of what you have described?
- Fully, yeah, a hundred
percent and that's,
that's what's missing from
the equation is really
any royal record of
what's going on at Angkor.
You don't know why Theravada
Buddhism sneaked in.
People have painted it
as a social revolution,
which is something that I have disputed.
And it's the continuity we see
in the archeological record,
indeed reflect the idea
that power is consolidated
and spaces remain sacred.
Again, why,
why not build something familiar
if you're working with familiar power?
So I fully agree with that.
- Andrew, thanks very much
for a very informative
and fascinating and
revealing presentation.
A lot of it was new to me
and I learned a lot from it.
I wonder if you would agree
that we're talking about a major
transformation in Cambodian society here,
not just a religious transformation,
but political and social transformation
as well in the 14th and 15th centuries,
and I wonder if you'd like to comment
on some of the traditional explanations
for that transformation
or those transformations
and how your explanation
and your observations
fit in to the sort of more longstanding
or traditional explanations.
You know, one of them that played around
for a long time is that
Jayavarman the seventh,
who built Angkor Thom
with his 40 year reign
and massive building program,
just (murmurs) source
to the Cambodian population and led to,
a major change in the popular
image of centralized,
centralized empire and kingdom,
and moved to a more village oriented
Theravada Buddhist society away
from a Hindu and Mahayana
Buddhist society.
But there are two other
more recent explanations which might,
I'd be interested to
hear your comments on.
One of them is that it was a change
in the world trade patterns
that the world trade going
past the south China sea,
made the option very attractive
for the Angkorian elites
to move further south down the river,
to be closer to the south China sea trade.
And Angkor was abandoned basically for an,
an inland agrarian society had changed
to a maritime commercial society.
And that might be something
that the Theravada Buddhism
and its adoption broadly across Cambodia
had something to do with,
that economic change.
- Yeah.
- And then
we have the climate explanation as well.
The 1300s where basically
the end of the medieval warm period,
it became much less wet,
a lot drier and more frequent
droughts in the 1300s
and early 1400s.
Does that have anything to
do with the transformation
that you're talking about?
And finally, just a quick question related
to what you're talking about.
I just wonder whether the dominance
in Jayavarman the seventh's
reign of Mahayana Buddhism,
which was unusual for compared
to previous Angkorian monarchs,
even though Mahayana Buddhism
was part of the religious
structure along with Hinduism.
But the unusual predominance
of Mahayana Buddhism,
was that in a way a kind
of transitional phase
towards a new kind of Theravada Buddhism,
and a Theravada Buddhist
transition that was made possible
rather than precipitated as
another explanation might have
it by, by Jayavarman the seventh's reign.
- So, as we know in the
1300s, in the 1200s,
right after the death of
Jayavarman the seventh,
Angkor got rocked by event
after event, after event.
First, mega monsoons and mega droughts
almost are believed to
have begun to decimate
the hydrology of Angkorians
and greater Angkor
most notably during that period.
Then you have the hypothesis
of the population of a plague
just of expansion from other qualities,
Sukhothai and Ayutthaya,
successively expanded during this period.
So, in terms of Theravada Buddhism,
even though these things
seem to correlate Jayavarman
exploited the resources of the capital.
As Lawrence Briggs wrote,
the Khmer got leaked by religion
or something that (murmurs) quote.
But it's very, it's very hard
and just not wise quite yet
to connect Theravada Buddhism
and any sort of social
upheaval to those events.
They seem to make sense.
But again, I'd like to see,
I just, as an archeologist,
I'd like to see the connection
between monastic construction
and any type of climatological fluctuation
in more than just,
more than just circumstantial events
happening around the same time.
It's means it's,
it's a very logical
explanation, but again,
dangerous, without more
evidence on my part, at least.
In terms of trade,
there was, I mean,
there's theories that the
focus moved to the Mekong Delta
before the traditional
sacrum of Angkor before.
I mean, it was a logical place
based on the trade wealth
in the south China sea that was coming in.
And I mentioned, as I mentioned,
we do have evidence of an
upper limit potentially
at Buddhist terraces at Angkor Thom,
based on those Chinese ceramic seriations.
The idea that there have not
been any blue and whites found.
Although there have been
blue and whites found out at
Angkor Wat by Alison Carter's
team or down by (indistinct).
So there's none up here yet, and you're,
there might be you do another
excavation on another site,
you might find some later occupation.
We're not finding that yet.
In terms of Jayavarman
and the introduction of
Theravada by way of Mahayana,
I think, as I mentioned,
that has more to do with the activity
and consolidation of the
frontier or the Western frontier
where Theravada Buddhism
was being practiced.
Around areas like Khmer you do populations
that are Buddhist and
had been for a while.
Sir Jayavarman the second
or the first is thought
to have been from Khmer.
The architecture of
(murmurs) under Jayavarman
was thought to be from Khmer.
And you might just simply
have more engagement on that
cultural frontier than you
otherwise would have in the past,
based on the repaving
and restructuring of the roads.
And so that creates a flood gate,
as well as if populations were
being absorbed under that,
under that in Germany.
Again, speculative and
needs more archeology,
needs more cooperative archeology.
And that's why I hesitate to
construct a narrative beyond
what we know from Zhou Daguan onwards.
- Thank you, very good.
- Thank you, Andrew.
We have another question from Louis Court.
Louise, if you can ask your
question.
- Yes.
I'm sorry, I can't turn on my
camera, it seems to be broken.
- Not problem, I see you.
- So you could go from
really broad and fascinating
questions to a very minute
point that you made in
passing, Andrew.
- Sure.
- My attention as someone interested
in the development of ceramic production
in the Angkor region.
You mentioned showing a
group of Chinese charts,
and were also finds,
and I believe it was
from the excavation of one
of the Buddhist terraces,
of the kinds of green glazed
or celadon blazed lidded boxes
that were a major product of the Khmer,
on top of Mount Kulen.
- Yes, and I talked to
(murmurs) about that and he was,
he was very happy about that.
That we were finding,
we only found them at two sites,
one of which was our
major excavation site,
where we found more
than a couple of shares.
And the other one was a
site that was surrounded
by the remains of the necropolis.
And those shirts were actually associated
with the basis of stupa.
So they may have been considered
luxury goods in that perspective.
- The production of cupboard
boxes like that goes back
to a point earlier than
the date you've been giving
for the introduction of Theravada,
by several centuries.
And so, I'm wondering whether
this is a very micro scale
example of how production of a
certain kind of object within
the Angkorian material culture
could be shifted in use from
some kind of offering
equipment for a Hindu context
into a Theravada Buddhist context?
- Sure, I was actually
thinking about this one
right after we excavated the boxes.
And there's kind of two
ways you can think about it.
The first is that those boxes
were considered ancient goods
and were considered and were
given as (murmurs) of deposits,
and then thus are kind of anachronistic.
The other is that they
were from an earlier
era of occupation on the same site.
On three of the four
sites that we excavated,
we found ceramic offerings or not,
sorry not ceramic offerings,
ceramic remains that dated from
an earlier period as sort of related
to the strategic graphy
of our radiocarbon dates.
And so there is a thought
that at least in one of,
at least with the site,
with the gypsum foundation stone we found,
which was actually surrounded
by bones and charcoal,
that you might have
the site of an earlier
religious occupation.
And then a,
that gives you more of why they may
have constructed the Buddhist
terrace where they did,
and b, you have
some context that's actually
temporarily appropriate
to where you find the box,
and it doesn't necessarily
throw things out of whack.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Again,
this is something to validate with more,
with more field work I think.
- Yes, please,
please do.
(all chuckling)
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you for that fascinating question.
And thank you, Andrew,
for such a wonderful
engaging talk in the Q and A.
- Thank you.
- What I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna stop the recording now
and then leave the chat open,
leave the session open for
another 15 minutes or so
for informal chit chat.
You can imagine this.
Everyone is after the talk.
You can come up to the podium
and chat with the speaker.
So, I will stop the recording right now
and please stay if you feel like it.